behind any commercial flight is more
than a century of political negotiation
and a court that dictate who how and
where airlines can fly aviation is one
of the most unifying industries
worldwide because it is what brings the
world together the beginning of aviation
agreements came with a 1944 Chicago
Convention on International Civil
Aviation this convention established the
UN oversight agency responsible for
civil aviation the International Civil
Aviation Organization the ICAO is
recognized by every country worldwide
except for Alishan Stein Dominica and
Tuvalu of those Tuvalu is the sole
country to have an International Airport
so that means that all but one sky fairy
nation worldwide is part of the ICAO
soon after its inception the ICAO laid
out five fundamental rights of aviation
known as the five freedoms of the air
which serve as a framework for
international aviation agreements each
freedom has varying levels of acceptance
but every developed country worldwide
grants these rights to certain foreign
airlines the first freedom of the air is
the right to fly over a foreign country
without landing pretty much every
commercial flight and commercial airline
is allowed to do this there are
exceptions the EU has a list of hundreds
supposedly unsafe airlines that are not
allowed in EU airspace but there are no
large airlines today restricted from
certain airspace it may seem like a
given that foreign airlines can over fly
countries but the airspace above a
country is sovereign territory of that
country more or less there isn't
actually an internationally recognised
line of separation between sovereign
airspace and space some say it's 19
miles above sea level the highest
altitude balloons and airplanes can fly
while others say it's as high as 99
miles the altitude of the lowest stable
orbits around Earth the u.s. classifies
anyone who's flown 50 miles or higher
above earth as an astronaut so that
therefore means that the u.s. recognizes
50 miles above earth as the beginning of
space however there are instances in
which the u.s. hasn't respected
sovereignty below
two miles when Space Shuttle missions
return to earth they did so much like an
airplane with a slow horizontal descent
down to a runway their descent paths
were so long that they had to descend
over foreign nations such as Canada
below 50 miles altitude and yet the u.s.
never requested permission from Canada
to fly in their airspace
just because airlines are allowed to fly
over foreign countries doesn't mean that
they can do so without restriction of
course they need to be in contact with
air traffic control but they also need
to pay what's known as over flight fees
over flight fees are how airlines pay
foreign countries they fly over but
don't land or take off in for the use of
their air traffic control services
airlines still have to pay to use air
traffic control in countries they land
or takeoff in but these fees are paid
and calculated in different ways
depending on the country over flight
fees are nearly universal the US for
example charges fifty six dollars and 86
cents per 100 nautical miles you may
think that these fees are fairly
inconsequential since the only
international flights that really fly
over the US without landing are flights
to/from or between Mexico Canada and
some Caribbean nations however the u.s.
is actually responsible for a huge
amount of airspace way larger than the
u.s. itself it was allocated this
airspace by the International Civil
Aviation Organization and since it
provides air traffic control for this
area it also charges over flight fees
this does mean weirdly that flights from
Australia New Zealand Papua New Guinea
and other Melanesian countries pay over
flight fees to the US when flying to
Northeast Asian destinations such as
Japan Korea and China in u.s. oceanic
air space however airlines only pay
$21.63 per 100 nautical miles it may
seem like these small charges would have
little effect but on long-haul flight
over flight fees can really add up
especially with the razor-thin airline
margins that you learned about in my why
flying is so expensive video airlines do
have to put consideration into where
they fly based on over flight fees
Canadian / flight fees are no tour
easily expensive they work on a variable
cost structure based on takeoff weight
and distance flown so I won't go into
actual numbers almost any flight
originating in the US has to fly through
expensive Canadian airspace in route to
Europe as you learned about in my video
about the North Atlantic tracks but
airlines do have strategies to lower
these costs the most efficient route
between San Francisco and Frankfurt goes
north through Montana up over Northeast
Canada then across Greenland Iceland and
down into Europe however airlines don't
always use this route on certain days
with certain wind and weather conditions
they'll fly east through the United
States then enter Canadian airspace
somewhere over Minneapolis or Chicago so
that they'll pay less in Canadian over
flight fees complicated route planning
software takes all the variables wait
weather over flight fees etc and figures
out which route is most financially
efficient even if it wastes time or fuel
moving on the second freedom of the air
is the right for airlines to land in
foreign countries for technical stops
essentially that means refueling modern
airplanes have ranges of up to 9000
miles so there's a little need anymore
for refueling stops but in the past they
were crucial for long-haul flights
Shannon Airport in western Ireland once
received hundreds of flights per day
despite being located in an
exceptionally rural area the nearest
large city to Shannon Limerick has a
population of less than 100,000 but
geographically Shannon Airport is the
nearest airport to the US so back when
airplanes had shorter ranges they make a
stop to refuel in Shannon before
continuing on to their continental
European destinations during the era of
the Soviet Union almost no airline had
permission to overfly the USSR so
airlines had to literally go the other
way around the earth nearly every flight
between Europe and Asia was routed with
a technical stop in Anchorage Alaska to
refuel obviously this was incredibly
inefficient today's direct Europe Asia
flights take between 10 and 12 hours but
back when they stopped in Anchorage they
took as many as 22 hours despite the
huge
range of airplanes today there are still
some flights that require refueling
stops Australia and New Zealand are
almost exactly on the opposite side of
the world from London so any flight
between the two places
has to make a stop somewhere on its
London Sydney flights Qantas airlines
makes a stop in Dubai and on flights
between London and Auckland Air New
Zealand stops in Los Angeles
it is expected however that within weeks
or days of this video going up Qantas
airlines will announce a new direct
route between Perth in Western Australia
and London with their 77 900
Dreamliner's which would be the first
direct commercial service in history
between Europe and Australia this 9,000
mile trek would take an immense 18 hours
to connect the two continents
the third freedom of the air is pretty
simple it's the right to fly
commercially from one's own country to
another country this is just like Air
France flying Paris to New York or
singapore airlines flying singapore to
do by almost every international airline
is granted this third freedom if the
fourth freedom is just the inverse of
this the right to fly commercially from
another country to one's own there are
really no instances where the third and
fourth freedoms are granted separately
if an airline is allowed to fly
somewhere they're also allowed to fly
back with passengers the fifth and final
official freedom is the right for an
airline to fly passengers between two
foreign countries on a flight
originating or terminating in their own
country
now this is very similar to the second
freedom and the second freedom and fifth
freedoms are often but not always
granted together with the second freedom
Qantas is allowed to stop in Dubai to
refuel but if they're granted the fifth
freedom Qantas is also allowed to pick
up new paying passengers in Dubai and
fly them to London some examples of this
freedom include Air India's new york
london hyderabad route which is allowed
to fly passengers between new york and
london Cathay Pacific's Hong Kong
Vancouver New York route which is
allowed to fly passengers between
Vancouver and New York and Ethiopian
Airlines anis
Dublin Los Angeles flight which is
allowed to fly passengers between Los
Angeles and Dublin but let's move on to
the sixth freedom it may seem a little
strange that there's a six freedom in
the five freedoms of aviation there are
actually nine total freedoms but only
the first five are recognized officially
in the ICAO s five freedoms treaty while
freedoms six through nine are widely
accepted they are not as Universal
except for number six the sixth freedom
is actually unbelievably common it's the
right for an airline to transport
passengers from one foreign country to
another via their own country this is
just like Air France taking passengers
from New York to Dubai via Paris or
Korean Airlines taking passengers from
Frankfurt to Tokyo via Seoul as you can
tell having six freedom rights is
basically a fancy way to say airlines
are allowed to connect passengers there
are whole airlines that operate almost
exclusively using six freedom rights Wow
airlines in Icelandair take passengers
from North America to Europe via
Reykjavik and Turkish guitar a Fiat and
Emirates Airlines take passengers mostly
between Europe Africa and Asia via their
Middle Eastern hubs while each of these
airlines do have some passengers only
taking a direct flight to their hub the
vast majority of their traffic is
connecting due to their Geographic
positions between population centers
I'll finish off by grouping the seventh
eighth and ninth freedoms together as
you'll see they're quite similar and
often come together the seventh freedom
allows an airline to fly between two
foreign nations without connecting on to
its home the eighth freedom is the right
for an airline to fly between two cities
in one foreign country while continuing
on to its own country and the ninth and
final freedom is the right for a foreign
airline to fly between two points in a
foreign country without continuing on to
its own country it's extremely rare for
these freedoms to be granted except for
in the European Union
you see the European Union has a single
aviation market meaning that any airline
registered in an EU country is allowed
to fly flights between to and from any
Airport in the EU budget airlines like
Ryanair and easyJet thrive
on this regulation despite being an
Irish airline Ryanair is allowed to fly
routes like Edinburgh to London Paris to
Lyon and other domestic routes in
foreign countries due to this single
aviation market there are almost no
other instances where foreign airlines
are allowed to fly domestic routes
Ryanair is also allowed to fly routes
between two other you countries like
Paris to Berlin and from other EU
countries to outside the EU such as
Barcelona to Fez Morocco this is also
how Norwegian Airlines is allowed to fly
long-haul from Sweden Denmark and the UK
to the US well more or less you may
recall that Norway is actually not part
of the European Union so they're not
part of the EU single aviation market
but interestingly Norwegian Airlines is
actually registered in Ireland Sweden
Denmark Finland and the UK in order to
gain access to the EU single aviation
market as well as the Open Skies treaty
that allows unlimited and unrestricted
flights between the EU and the US
there's one really interesting use of
these treaties and regulations in the
form of short haul flights between the
Caribbean and the United States
Norwegian Airlines offers flights during
the winter months from Boston New York
and Baltimore to Martinique and
Guadeloupe and these aren't extensions
to their long-haul flights using fifth
freedom rights these are standalone
flights in small airplanes Boston and
Baltimore don't even have Norwegian
transatlantic flights normally a flight
like this would never be allowed but
since Martinique is an overseas region
and Guadeloupe is an overseas territory
of France they're also part of the EU
single aviation market and the Open
Skies treaty so those are the five or
rather nine freedoms of aviation
aviation is a very politically charged
and complicated subject but these
freedoms do a great job of simplifying
and standardizing airline regulations
worldwide I hope you enjoyed this win
over productions video videos like these
are made possible by my amazing patreon
supporters every dollar contributed on
my patreon is spent directly on the
channel and I'm held to that by
releasing an expense report at the end
of each month what's great about that is
that you can be sure that any dollar you
contribute
to my patreon we'll come back to you in
the form of a better video supporters
also get great rewards like t-shirts
stickers handwritten letters early
access to videos and more I do hope
you'll consider contributing over at
patreon.com slash win over productions
I'd also like to give a quick shout out
to shutterstock.com they're not a
sponsor but they do provide me with a
ton of great stock footage that I use to
improve these videos so please do go
check them out other than that please
follow me on twitter at 1-over Pro watch
my last video on economies of scale
check out my fan moderated subreddit at
wwe.com slash are slash win over
productions and most of all subscribe to
this channel thanks again for watching
and I'll see you in two weeks for
another whenever productions video